abone ol
[Alkış]
bu Merhabalar hepiniz hoşgeldiniz Ben bu
şans Doktor yazdı Bingöl Alpaslan
fizikçiyim ama bugün burada konuşma
müzik diyerek başlamak istiyorum
Öncelikle günlük yaşantımızda koşuşturma
larımızı yorgunluğunu alan meditasyon
niteliğinde affettiririz vardır yani
birçoğunun vardır diye düşünüyorum ama
yoksa bir de olmalı sizi İyi hissettiren
sizi mutlu hissettiren başkaları nasıl
hissettirdi inadına önemli değil benimki
müzik dinlemeye bayılıyorum dinleyerek
kalsam sıkıntı yok ama bir de şarkı
söylemeyi kalkıyorum O zaman olaylar
birazcık karışıyor küçüklüğümden beri
böyleydi bu aslında yıllardır
biriktirdiğim çok da geliştirme perform
oldu içinde bulunduğu durum şartları
Neyi gerektiriyorsa benimle pantolonumda
o Esra bir şekilde ortaya döken ortaya
çıkar ve kendini ben de onu söylerken ve
dinlerken bulurum kulaklıkla bütün hali
değil arkada Beklerken heyecandan bir
şeyler uyguluyorum yine Ama buraya
gelince Sustum Tabiki Çünkü gerçekten
susmayacağım düşünen Arkadaşların falan
var söyleyeceksin Az önce konuşacaksın
biliyorsunuz deli gibi tabii ki
söyleyeceğim merak
etmeyin dediğim gibi bu şekilde
temsilcilerle ta kimlerle geliyorum ama
topla kötü bir Sesim yok yaklaşık üç
buçuk dört yıldır ilgili sunum en eski
Hatta Türkiye'nin en eski cennetlerinden
biri birisi Musiki cemiyeti'nde polis
olarak görev yapıyorum ama koray'ı buz
gibi bir durum olsa emin olmuş şefimiz
öyle bir şekilde hocamız var ki anında
sizi kenara bertaraf eder ama buçuk Dört
sene içerisinde hocanın size bir sola
versek mi ya da hafif hafif cihetle
başlasak mı tarzında herhangi bir 8
gelmemiş olması da bireysel olarak bu
konuda biraz daha eğitim almam
gerektiğini gösteriyor dedim ya az önce
küçüklüğümden beri böyleyim diye çok iyi
hatırlıyorum annemle birlikte bir otobüs
yolculuğu yapıyoruz Yerimde duramıyorum
şarkı söylüyor otobüs full dolu mavi
dayanamıyor beni ağzı gibi şoför beni
yanına götürüyor mikrofon veriyor Hadi
başlasam bu ne geliyor Ben tabii ki
başlıyorum şarkı söyle ve karşınıza
gülen yüzler alkış Bu gereksiz özgürlüğü
seni o günlere dayanıyor Tabii ki
söylediğim şarkı da o zamanlar benim de
çok özdeşleşmiş İbrahim Tatlıses'in don
don konuştu Kızım şu an burada burada
göremiyorum ama büyük bir ihtimalle
kışın kaldırıp anne sıkıntıya göre
eminim merak etmeyin gerçekten
söyleyeceğim derken yıllar geçtim Hayat
büyütüyor olgunlaştırıyor dokuz yaşına
geldim benimle özdeşleşen yeni bir
şarkım oldu şarkıda ne Derdimi Kimlere
Desem Işıl alıp verelim insan bu aşk
beni öldürecek candanmı yardanmı
gelirsen babacığım bana öğrettiği bir
şarkıydı bu bu benden dinle artık ben
bana söyledi iç dişli dinlerdim ben
tabii o zamanlar çok güzel söylediğimi
düşünürdüm Ama anladım ki çok da değil
aslında derken
yıllar geçtim şimdi o kadar tabii ki Alt
Bu çizgi film sempatik oluyor her
şarkıyı söylemek ama şarkıları iki var
bir şarkıda geçen küçücük bir cümle O an
size bir insanın kullanacağı kuracağı
bir Cümleden çok daha fazla hayatınızda
dokunabiliyor insan ve cümleleri çok
samimiyetsiz Olabilir çünkü ama şarkılar
asla bu kadar şarkı şarkı demişken
sizlerinde beş saniye bir şarkı üstüne
çekmek istiyorum çoğumuzun bildiği bir
şarkıdır Aslında sevgili Erkin Koray'ın
Öyle Bir Geçer Zamanki dediğim aynıyla
vaki birden Dursun istersin seneler
olunca mazi Şimdi size sorsam bir saniye
düşün desem hepimizin bugüne kadar
geçirdiği bir hikayesi var ise 10
yaşında olun ister 80 yaşında Şu an
şuraya kadar getirdiği sonrasını
bilemediğimiz ne hissedersiniz gözünüzü
kapattığınızda ilk aklımıza gelen çok
güzel anılar sana ne güzel söylemiş
Erkin baba Keşke kanserdi o zaman içinde
dersiniz Ama yok Bir zamanımızı çok kötü
anlarımız geldiyse Ya yok Erken Baba
hayat sana güzel durması iyi o gitmiş
bir daha ararsam o günleri ki olsun
dersiniz Sonuç olarak Hangisi ağır
basarsa Ama biraz daha uzun düşünsek
Aslında görürüz ki hepimizin hayatında
mutluluk kavuştuğumuz için de kaldığımız
Keşke akıp gitmezse dediğiniz ama
zamanın bir o kadar hızlı akıp isyanlar
vardır bazen de öyle almak için de
kendimizi buluruz ki ölüyorum zannederiz
Ölmeyiz acı içinde kıvranır ız Allah'ım
bir an önce geçip gitsin dedim ama
zamanda inadına oraya mıhlanır kalır bir
zaman bizimle derdine nedenin Adımızı
istiyor asla baktığınızda zaman sizinle
bir derdi yok fizikçi olarak cevap
verebilirim buna Einstein çok güzel
sevgili az bu Saçlar çok güzel ifade
etmiş Zalim İzafiyet teorisini
anlatırken bunu yaşına kadar aşağıda
söyledi de tartıştık kaynaktan kaynağa
göre değişiyor mu çok güzel ifade eder
Neymiş ki elinizi sıcacık bir sorunun
üstünde bir dakika Tutun bir saat gibi
gelir güzel bir hanımefendi ile bir saat
sohbet edin bir dakika git geçer bu O
hanımefendi Einstein hayatı söylemiş
olabilir mi söylemiş Olabilir Sonuç
olarak baktığımızda ilk Ne geldiyse ne
gelirse gelsin hepsi geçti İyi geçti
kötüde Geçti isteseniz de geçti
istemeseniz de yerleştirdik herşey Bu
kadar çabuk geçip Bir dakika şu an bile
birazdan geçip gidecekken
bizim elimizde kalan de bizlerin elinde
kalan bugüne kadar geçirdiğimiz
Hikayemiz Şimdi siz bu kadar hikaye
demeyeceğim hikaye anlatmak istiyorum
zeka biz iki ana kahramanı var birinci
kahramanımız hayatı hayat dolu
insanların gezmeye yaşamayı çok seven
İstanbul'da yaşayan iki çocuğu olan bir
beyaz artık bu Fakat bu kahramanımızın
Yüksek tansiyon problemi var devamlı
yükselen tansiyonu ancak hastanelerde
müdahale edecek düşünebiliyor kendisine
daha önce yapılan tetkiklerde Beyninde
bir şeye rastlandığı çok dikkat etmesi
gerektiği söyleniyor ama kahramanı o
kadar hayatta ne yapmalı ki söylenen bir
ciddiye almıyor Ya da alamıyor inanın
orayı ben de bilmiyorum bir tatil için
geldiği memleketinde henüz 35
yaşındayken bir sokak köşesinde olduğu
yere yığılıyor anlaşılıyor ki beyin
kanaması geçirmiş vücudunun sağ tarafı
saat olmuş
kendisi ve ailesi için çok zor bir süreç
başlıyor hep bir hayatları sıfırdan
duruyorlar İstanbul'dan memleketlerine
dönüyorlar kahramanımız çalışmadığı için
malulen emekli oluyor Sadece işte
Çalışıyor derken bu hayata alışmaya
çalışıyorlar Az önce bahsettiğimiz şu
zaman var yani şu zaman sanki bu sefer
bize iyi geliyorsun belli bir tane
cidden almaya başlıyor yıllar geçiyor
kahramanımız Yavaş yavaş yürümeye
başlıyor konuşmaya başlıyor yemeğini
kendi yemeğe hayata tutunmaya başlıyor
yıllar böyle geçerken dört yıl sonunda
bir gün bir sabah uyandığında
tuhaflık hissediyor kendinde Sanki ben
bunu daha önce yaşamıştım hissiyle o
gözlerinin içine bakarak Allah'ın sakın
diye başladı cümlesini tamamlayamadan
olduğu yere yığılıyor anlaşılıyor ki
ikinci kez beyin kanaması geçirmiş mu
sefer saç sol tarafına vurmuş Tam da her
şey yolunda giderken değil mi hayatta
bazen başımıza gelir ya değer
verdiklerimiz Biz aldattığında yalan
söylediğinde benim hayal kırıklığına
uğrattığında hiç seni çekici bir şans
var mı ikisini de çevremizdeki insanlar
bölümü mantıklı mantıklı bakan
insanlardan yaz dur yapma İlkinde
yaralayan İkincide öldürür ben bu hikaye
de İlk önce bunu öğrendim Biz diğer
insanlara değer verdiğimiz gibi önce
kendi vücudumuza bedenimize devam etmek
zorunda almışız Çünkü aynı anda
denildiği gibi bedeliniz için de geçerli
bir çözümle İlkinde yaralı bırakan
tavsiye bırakan beyin kanaması
ikincisinde kahramanımızı kırk gün
geçmeden henüz kırk yaşını doldurmadan
yaşanmışlıkları hayal edip
yaşayamadıkları yla hikâyesinden kopar
bir
kahramanın hikayesi bitti ama ana hikaye
devam etmek zorunda eşi derken başrolü
kapıyor hikaye götürmek zorunda bir
hikaye en çok etkileyen bu eşit aslında
da hala çok etkisindeyim
İyi o zaman işi rahatsızlandı denizin
beş yaşındaydı onu kaybettiğinde s29
yaşındaydı çok gençlik güzel bir kadın
çok daha güçlü bir karakter ama o sıra
bu gücünü zerre kadar farkında değil
aslında bir çoğunuz gibi insanın ne
kadar güçlü olduğunu fark edilmişse o
kadar kolay bir şey değildir içimizdeki
gücü ortaya çıkaran yaşadığımız acı
tecrübeler verdiğimiz Zorlu sınav vardır
Bu kadın kahramanımız da iki çocuğuyla
küçücük bir şehirde üzerine yüklenmiş
yükleri ve etiketleriyle de yapacağını
bilmez bir şekilde kalıyor önce kendine
bir koruma alamıyordum diye yaratıyor
Tabiri caizse kendisi ve çocukları bir
tanrı su içine kapatıyor böyle
yapmayalım böyle davranmayın şöyle olur
böyle bir paraları ya basitçe pompalı
koruma alanı yaratıyor ama Zaman
geçtikçe
anlıyor ki bu kendisi ve çocukları bufam
su içinde boğulacak ve çok zor bir karar
veriyor O an kendi için bütün
çevresindeki herkesi itiraz etmesine
rağmen abi Ne oldu kırmak zorundayım
burada bu şehirde istediğim gibi
çocuklarını büyüteceğim eğitim yiyeceğim
düşüncesiyle falan sıkılıyor ve daha
büyük bir şey de taşınıyorlar eğitimin
falan eğitim imkânlarının çok farklı
olduğu ufukların çok farklı açılacağı
derken gerçekten de
gidiyor yerleşiyorlar ve hayatları
değişiyor ayakları ikinci kez değişiyor
ve kahramanlarımızla değişiyor insan
değiştirdi tartışma konusu Ben bunu hala
net bir şey söyleyemiyorum Ama çok iyi
bildiğim bir şey var İnsan çok güzel
evleniyor yeter ki istesin bizim
kahramanlarımız değil diyor Tabii ki de
babasını kaybettiğinde 11 yaşında yeni
doldurmuş olan kız çocuğu için biraz
durum farklı tabi babasına çok düşkün
Babasıyla çok güzel bir bağı var çok
baba kız gibi Tabii ki hatta bahısnow
ikinci tacizden sonra kırk gün boyunca
sadece gözleriyle konuşabilen babanın
kuru bildiği tek bir kelime var
söyleyebildi o da kızın adı Bu hikayede
baba kızını tutunarak yürümeye başlıyor
beraber bu Getiriyorlar en sevdikleri
şey futbol maçı izlemek kız koyu bir
Beşiktaşlı babasından öğreniyor futbolu
o yaşlarda hangi şöyle der yani Kadınlar
olsaydı anlatırsa evlenelim falan kız 11
yaşında sizi Oo sadece o kadar güzel
anlatır ki ama şimdi takım sadece siniz
Metin Ali Feyyaz Şifo Mehmet Takoz Recep
mide takoz Recep'i bu şekilde sıralar
büyük bir ihtimalle Çünkü o gün orada
babasını babasıyla birlikte futbol ve
Beşiktaş'ı bırakıyor derken bir süre
içerisinde
babaanneleri çok düşkün oldu Babaanneme
dedesinin evlat acısıyla nasıl bir sene
içinde iple aldıklarını fark ediyor ve
üç ay içerisinde bir sene sonunda peş
peşe onları kaybediyor henüz 11 yaşında
ölümden kelimeyle Çok içli dışlı bir
hale geliyor Bu kız çocuğunu babasını
kaybettiği dönemlerde onun etkisiyle
midir bizim az bildiğiniz psikolojideki
adıyla sosyal ko bitmiş hangi ismi
söylendiğinde Kızaran bu sorulduğunda ne
yapacağını bilemeyen fırından gidip
ekmek istemek hayatın Erzurum işiymiş o
dönemde o ekmeği alırmış ama gelirken
yolda stres da ekmek sarılı olduğu
kağıda benim sıcağım diye kağıt para
üzerini yırtık çok fazla serisinden olan
fırçayı yermiş ama annenin verdiği bu
pozitif kararlı hayatları değişir
değiştiğinde Hani evlenmişler ya bu kız
çocuğu o kadar evrilmiş o kadar evrilmiş
ki bugün karşınızda telefon konuşması
yapıyor
şekilde
iki ayağından kısacık bir özeti bu Ben
Bu hikayede yaş içerisindeyken kim
üzüleceğim Çok fazla bilememişsin
kardeşime kendime aynı babama ayrı
Anneme çok ayrı diyordum ama hikaye
ilerledikçe gerçekten sadece hikayesi
çok çok erken biten babama üzülüyorum
daha sonra bu hikaye de en çok şeyi
annemden öğrendim sağlıksız çocuklar
gibi görünmekle birlikte Bence dün iyi
bir insansın çocuklarıydık çünkü anneme
sahiptik annemden öğrendiğim şeylerin
Başında Bir kadın isterse ne kadar güçlü
olabileceğini etrafı ne kadar güzel top
arayabileceğiniz öğrendim başınızın bu
konuda onun kadar bilmiyorum ama Fena
değilim bir karar verdiğinizde
hayatınızda ilgili bir şey yapmak
istediğinizde benim çevremde çok güzeldi
hepinize de vardır yapamazsın edemezsin
dur kolay değil hayatını alt üst olur
bir olumsuz insanlar da olumsuz
kelimeler bir Allah onlara da eksik
etmesin acayip motivasyon kaynağı
kendileri ama zorluyorlar Tabii ki
bunlar ama bütün olumsuzluklara rağmen
inandığı yolda dik durmaya ve devam
etmen gerektiğini devam etmek zorunda
olduğunu öğrendim hepsini bir ya hayatın
gerçekten denildiği gibi hayatın altının
üstünden güzel olabileceğini öğrendi
babamın hastalığı ve kaygı süresince o
beş yıl içerisinde hayatımız iki kez
baştan aşağı değiştiğinde insanların
meclis aldıklarında ya gerçekten hayatı
sıfırdan başlayabilecek bu konuda çok da
düşünüldüğü gibi korkunç bir şey
olmadığını öğrendim
bu hayattaki tek gerçeğin ölüm olduğunu
hep söylerlerse çare bulamadığımız
gerçekten hayattaki tek gerçek ölüm
olduğunu ama bunu ancak çok yakınınızı
kaybettiğinizde anlayabileceğiniz
öğrendim babamı kaybettiğimde gerçekten
11 yaşından beri bir parçanın eksik
hayatın devam etti mezun olduğu yok
evlilik eğlendim yok çocuğum oluyor
bazen koşarak bir şey anlatmak
istediğinde büyük bir mutluluğunu
paylaşmak istediğinde yok ama bir
taraftan da bunu insanı çok büyük Sen
hayatı daha sıkı bağlayan bu ufacık
şeylerden mutlu olmasını sağlayan bir
şey olduğunu öğrendim beni tanıyan
insanlar Özellikle sosyal medyada çok
farklı bir sosyal medyada takip edenleri
söylediği bir cümle var hocam ya hayat
sana güzel Hiç mi Derdi tasarruflu
enerji şekilde yorum yaparlar harbi
bilmezler gibi bir tercihtir mutluluk
inanın bir tarih Bazı şeylerin olumsuz
şeylerin içinden çıkabilmek değil
mutluluk mücadeledir
bir tabi böyle bir daha güzel anlattım
çok güzel kendimde söylüyorum fizikçi
olarak da çok iyi bildiğim bir şey var
Bu hikayede öğrendiğim sosis son önemli
şeylerden Bir tanesi çok deneyi
yaptığınız teorik ve pratik çok uymaz
gerçekten
en son dört yıl öncesine kadar da bu
söylediklerimi çok güzel geldim ama dört
yıl önce mesleğinde çok hayaletli bir
noktaya geldim ama bu sırada üst üste
yaşadığım haksızlıklar Bir de geldim üst
üste gelmek gelir derler ya sadece
mesleki değil çok şehrinizde yani ne
oldu inanın önemli bir çocuğun hayatında
olabilecek şeyler baktım ki o pozitif
İnsan kendi hikâyesinden bir sürü ders
çıkarıp insan çok lanet bir insan haline
geldi bana bunu yaptılar bana bunu dedi
derken bir o kendine Tabii ki Yani
kendini zarar vereceğinden Benimki bunu
bunu nasıl yaptılar neden yaptılar böyle
kendimi Devamlı devamlı eziyete derken
hani konuşmamın başında dedim ya
vücudumuz belirtiniz sevmeniz lazım Özen
göstermeniz lazım diye bir gün bana
dediler ki Tam da babamı yaşındayım ve
elinizde ufak bir şeye rastladık Ama bu
ama çok sihirli bir kelime bir Bence
kendinden öncekini çürütür aslında seni
çok se Ama siz abi seni çok seviyorum
onu Çünkü sonunda gelecek şey 13
yürütecektir ama ben olmadan sonrasını
duymadım orada olduğum yerde kaldım Ve
anladım ki bir şeyler oluyor hemen
aklıma gelen kızım an olacak Dıbık
yaşında annemi göremeyeceğim çizdiğim
senaryoları anlatamam size tam de
vuruyorum gibi bulmak üzereyim dedim ki
dur Allah'tan en güzel uzaktan takip
kendimi çok Biliyorum hatta hayat beni
çok kendimi bilmiyorum bence çok güzel
bir şey bu dur dedim durdum
ben bir sürü şey gördüm babanı kaybettin
Sana ne oldu Hiçbir şey olmadı Kızıma da
bir şey olmayacak Senin Hikayen bitecek
ama sonra anladım ki olmadan sonrası
biraz dinleyici biraz araştırıcı üstünde
durunca bir çoğunuz yaşayabileceği gibi
bi çok önemli şey olmadığını takip
ederek devam edeceğiz öğrendim O günden
sonra da ne oldu Kendi seven kız çocuğu
daha çok sevmeye başladı daha da çok
şarkı söylemeye başladı bu işte bir
zararı Yoksa kimseye zarar vermiyorsa
üzerindeki etiketler ne olursa olsun
kendi gibi olmaya devam ettim hikayeniz
nasıldır bilmiyorum hepimizin
hikayelerinden birbirinize birbirimizi
öğreteceğim şeyler olduğunu düşünüyorum
belki daha iyi Belki daha kötü bunu da
şiddetle karşı çıkıyorum aslında ama
Hani derler ya senden kötüleri örnek
alıyor Bunu Ne Olur İzin vermeyin
herkesin hikayesi kendine ağırdır
kendine özeldir bir tanedir önemli olan
o hikayeyi içerisinde ne yaşarsınız
yeşil ölüm bile olsa sağlıkla
çıkabilmektir lütfen hikayenize
Kendimizi ezdirmeyin de mümkün
olabildiğince dimdik çıkmaya çalışın
dinlediğiniz için Çok teşekkürler
sevgilerimle
[Alkış]